como yo vi mi de 220 centímetros quería
llenar su piscina de manera que la
altura del agua fuera la misma que la de
él el nivel del agua aumentó 6
centímetros cada minuto y llego a la
altura deseada después de 20 minutos
interesante nos dice gráfica el nivel
del agua en centímetros como una función
del tiempo en minutos muy bien así que
este es un problema de graficar una
función lineal ya que tenemos una tasa
de cambio constante verdad
vamos a ver cómo hacerlo aquí hubo un
dato muy interesante que nos dice aquí
el enunciado menciona que llegó a la
altura deseada después de 20 minutos
verdad pero cuál era la altura deseada
bueno quería que tuviera la altura del
agua a la misma altura que la de él y la
de él es de 220 centímetros eso quiere
decir que a los 20 minutos de haber
empezado a llenar de agua obtuvimos 220
centímetros muy bien
ahora tenemos que determinar qué ocurre
con este segundo punto y quizás tú
estarás tentado a decir bueno pues al
inicio no había agua así que en el
tiempo cero empezamos con cero
centímetros del nivel del agua sin
embargo eso no nos lo dicen en el
ejercicio puede ser que haya no sé que
hubiera algo de agua al inicio en
nuestra en nuestra piscina verdad eso no
nos lo dice el problema así que no
podemos suponer lo muy bien sin embargo
si nos dice que la tasa de cambio del
nivel del agua aumenta o bueno que la
tasa de cambio es de 6 centímetros cada
minuto verdad el nivel del agua aumenta
6 centímetros cada minuto así que qué
hubiera pasado cada 10 minutos es decir
si nosotros aquí nos encontramos en el
minuto 20 donde nos hubiéramos
encontrado en el minuto 10 y bueno si
nosotros sabemos que son 6 centímetros
lo que aumenta por cada minuto en 10
minutos habrá aumentado
a 60 centímetros verdad y si nos
encontrábamos aquí en 220 pues hace 10
minutos tenemos que restar 60 verdad
aquí van 20 40 60 tendríamos que estar
en 160 muy bien entonces aquí tenemos ya
resuelto el problema vamos a ver si sí
estamos en lo correcto en principio y de
hecho coincide con lo que habíamos
observado al inicio verdad en al inicio
el agua tenía una altura de 100
centímetros es decir no estaba vacía
verdad entonces si aquí se encuentra en
100 centímetros después de 20 minutos
hemos aumentado bueno de 100 a ciento a
220 verdad entonces hemos aumentado 120
centímetros en 20 minutos si nosotros
dividimos 120 entre 20 obtenemos 6
centímetros cada minuto verdad así que
esto pinta muy bien para la respuesta
ahí
es correcto